So it's actually just freedom in
Christian religion.
>> Yes. Which is the only true religion.
Many 7th day Adventists really place a
very high premium on this specific day
as if it has salvific ramifications
which would be a very serious concern
for me.
>> Can somebody remain in salvific
condition if they are knowingly
willfully violating any other
commandment in God's law?
>> In the new covenant there is a new
Sabbath. I do not see remember the first
day to keep it holy. There's only one
definition of the Lord's day, and it's
always been the Sabbath, and it's
unchangeable.
>> And this is, I think, where it gets
tricky. It would be much easier if my
7th Day Adventist friends just started
to acknowledge Sunday as the Lord's day.
Then that way, we wouldn't run into
those kinds of issues.
>> Back in 1895, you had 7th Day Adventists
that were persecuted for doing work on
their own property. And it made national
headline news across the United States.
>> God has created people. God has created
institutions to be ruled by something.
>> One of the books that we have right here
is actual canon law. When it talks about
the pope, it actually shows himself to
be God. This is the power that changed
God's times and laws.
>> So the question is when God blesses
something, can he reverse it? Because he
blessed the Sabbath day, he blessed the
seventh day. Everybody will have to go
to the scriptures and determine for
themselves which of the two do they
think fit the pattern of scripture the
best and that is a personal choice that
each one of us has to make.
>> Welcome back to Heritage and Hope
Ministries. Today we have a very special
episode with a remarkable lineup of
guests. Some of us joining us right here
in the studio and others connecting with
us from around the globe. Uh returning
to this conversation is Lennox Kalifunga
from New St. Andrews College. He's a
writer, a speaker, and the host of the
podcast of Flames and Crowns where he
explores theology, culture, and the
Christian life. Also joining us once
again is Christopher Bon. Thank you for
joining us. President of Network 7
Media, the producer of Mission Sunlight.
Through some short films and podcasts,
Christopher and his team spotlight
missionary efforts across the globe. And
for the first time, we're honored to
welcome Walter Vice and Martin Smith,
joining us all the way from South
Africa. Um, Dr. Vice is a well-known
author and evangelist whose work focuses
on creation, science, and end time end
time prophecy. And Martin Smith has been
the co-host and co-director with Dr. Ve
for many years. Many of you will
recognize them from their YouTube
channel, Clash of Minds, and the popular
program What's Up Prof, where they break
down current events through a biblical
and prophetic lens. And of course, your
host, James and myself are here
representing Heritage and Hope
Ministries. Our work focuses on
uncovering Protestant history through
rare books and documents, our oldest,
this one right here, dating back to
1559, alongside in-depth study of
scripture, prophecy, and current events.
Uh, so we're going to have links in the
description down below for all of the
YouTube channels represented here
because we're all Christian content
creators.
>> Amen.
>> Um, so let's dive into the conversation.
Um, Christopher, can you kind of start
us off with a brief word of prayer?
>> Absolutely. Our Father, which art in
heaven, hallowed and holy is your name
in all the earth. Right now, Father, we
ask that your holy spirit will be
present across the miles that as we
speak and share and learn and grow, that
you will be present in your name. Amen.
So, I want to say hello to Lennox. Uh,
Lennux, I really enjoyed connecting with
you last time and talking a bit about
our connection through Zambia and South
Africa, places that you have lived and
done ministry and then to be able to
have Martin and um, Walter join us from
South Africa today. It's like we we've
got a whole full circle here. We're
outnumbering the other two guys. So, um,
anyway, it's it's good to see you again,
and I'm I'm I'm happy that as we have
this dialogue, we can have a a civil
discourse about what scripture says
about what's coming and how to
appropriately and and properly prepare
for it. So, good to see you again.
>> Yeah. Well, thank you. It's good to see
you, too. Um, really enjoyed our
conversation last time, so uh, I count
this a great privilege. Thank you,
>> James.
>> Yeah. Um, so before we begin, I I once
again I just wanted to thank you so
much, Lennox, for joining us. I I kind
of think that last episode might have
been one of I think maybe your most
watch watched episodes on YouTube
perhaps. Um so it kind of uh exploded
and we're we're very appreciative of
that. You know um a lot's been happening
over the past couple of weeks in the
United States. Uh we've been watching uh
actually some of the movers and shakers
in the United States Senate um moving
forward. Perhaps a candidate from
Project 2025
who was advancing a uh a plan or a
strategy to amend the Fair Labor
Standards Act to bring about Sabbath
laws. I know one thing that we talked
about last time was was the Sabbath and
Sunday legislation and whatnot. Um, and
I felt like we both could probably have
a lot more questions about that. U
certainly that's being something that's
dialogued a lot in today's uh time
periods. It was something that was
dialogued as probably the hottest topic
of the Reformation if you go back to the
Auxburg confession article 28 where it
was it was one of the most hotly debated
topics. So, one of the things that you
said last time which really got me
thinking was that you said that you were
in favor of the general equity of the
law and and and so in a sense it sounded
like you were framing it as like well
you know the general equity or general
principle and kind of distancing from
choosing a particular day but the reason
why I wanted to follow up on that is I
went back and checked and some of the
dialogues between some of the
individuals coming out of New St.
Andrews College. So Jared Longshore,
Teimone Klein sitting down. They did not
seem in favor of the general equity
principle of the law. In fact, they were
very much uh stating specifically we
want to make it very certain which day
that we intend to honor. So I wanted to
get your thoughts about about that as we
get started here because um from from
our perspective, the general equity
principle that you talked about does not
seem to be reflected in what they're
advocating for. They're very specific
about which day they want to codify in
law.
>> Right. So to that I mean it would be I
will I will say start by beginning and
saying that um I'm sure these gentlemen
would be more than happy to elaborate um
their positions on this. Uh what I can
tell you for sure is that we all are
agreed on I think some of the
fundamental principles of political
theology and undergirling all that is
the idea that Christ truly is king that
he truly reigns and he truly rules over
all things and that his word has spoken
into every single aspect of life under
his kingship. So I think that we we'd be
greatly agreed there. Um the wonderful
thing about um our camaraderie is the
fact that it's not going to look
absolutely identical. Um and so there
are some things that they would
emphasize that I wouldn't emphasize and
the different things that I would
emphasize that they wouldn't. Uh but we
all rest on the same fundamental
principle.
in in my understanding of what I'd
consider the general equity of the law,
the general equity in the application of
the law, um this is basically a
reference to the fact that God's law is
timeless. It is universal and it is
timeless and it is relevant for not just
uh the past, not just for um historical
nations, but it is good and right for us
uh to employ that law uh today. Um but
of course because we're not in the past
and we're not exactly like the nations
of old and because we are in um the
administration of the new covenant um as
opposed to the old covenant um there are
some differences in the way that we that
we treat the law. Um it's not exactly
the same as it was in the old covenant.
And I think in the new covenant uh you
see a more perfect law. uh you see the
culmination of the intent of God's
original law and Christ still gives us
the same principles of the law which he
so aptly summarized with the statements
loving the Lord your God with all your
heart soul and mind which is a reference
to the first table of the law and loving
your neighbor neighbor as yourself which
is a summary of the second table of the
law um and so that principle continues
that's a that's a principle that Christ
continues to uphold that's uh uh that
that's a principle that the apostles
continue to uphold. And so we still see
this as the pattern in the new covenant,
but all of it still resting on the
premise that God is God. Um that he is
truly three in one, which means the son
of God, Jesus Christ is truly God, and
that he is um he is Lord of lords. He is
king of kings. He rules over all things
and has a law that is good for the
nations. And so that's that that in in
summary would be what I meant by the
general equity of the law.
>> How do you define that fundamental
principle? The the term you use the
fundamental principle. What is that?
Define that.
>> Um basically the fundamental principle
I'm referring to really is in reference
to the kingship of Christ. Okay. Uh so
because Christ is king um and because
he's king over absolutely all you know 1
Corinthians 6:15 refers to his
sovereignty truly as king of kings and
lord of lords and because he's king over
absolutely everything his word speaks to
absolutely everything. Um he is the
creator of the cosmos and not just the
creator but the ruler of the cosmos.
There's no square inch of the cosmos
over which he does not preside, over
which he does not rule, over which he
does not reign.
>> And that's why his his word is not
narrowly focused on just one aspect of
life. Um it is cosmological in its
scope. Um because Christ is king of the
cosmos. He is truly sovereign over
absolutely everything. So I'd say that's
the the basic principle and it's upon
that principle that everything rests
which means in our understanding of
politics
uh rulers and um magistrates ought to
submit to Jesus Christ as king um in
entirely. They are not the architects of
good or evil. They are not even the
architects of law. uh they are simply
those who uphold a law that God has
already given us and seeking to wisely
apply that um in a way that will enable
people to be free and in a way that will
enable people to flourish.
>> Walter Martin is if Christ is king
overall, which I believe he is, uh does
he need humans to
enforce his law? If if I can answer
from history,
when the Jews tried to set up a kingdom
where they would rule and where they
could uh have dominion over the nations
and set up
a theocracy, as it were,
that was swept away when Christ came and
he set up a kingdom
which he claimed had come near through
his coming to this earth. The kingdom
has come near to them to you and the
Bible says many are pressing into that
kingdom.
He also said to Pilate that my kingdom
is not of this world because if it were
then my servants would fight. So what he
was referring to is a spiritual kingdom
into all those who made a choice to
follow him would enter by faith.
So it was not a a a spiritual kingdom of
rule by earthly powers. It was a kingdom
that was to be called together and
composed of people led by the Holy
Spirit to accept Jesus Christ as the
savior of the world, as your personal
king within this kingdom and being
subjected to the rules and regulations
which are part of his kingdom. And those
are clearly stipulated in the Bible and
the ten commandments are part of that
law.
But never do you find within that system
that an earthly power was set up to
enforce it. The church was a spiritual
entity. It never all it never uh stayed
within those realms and the the conflict
arose when political power was added to
the spiritual power and that set up a
system where through the state the
church could control conscience. when
Protestantism
uh took part of of of that kingdom setup
away from the middle ages sort of setup.
They tried to do exactly the same thing
in Europe and set up parallel structures
ruled by Protestantism
and the state rather than by Catholicism
and the state. And these ran in parallel
and led to much much bloodshed.
That is why the founding fathers when
the United States was set up were so
adamant that church and state should be
separate because the spiritual realm was
to be governed by a calling of the Holy
Spirit. So we have we have two
philosophies here. one which claims that
the state should actually regulate these
things and one that that states that the
Holy Spirit is calling people into a
kingdom relationship which will only
culminate when Christ comes again to set
up his kingdom and the earthly kingdoms
according to Daniel chapter 2 will be
eliminated
and the Bible is very clear about that.
So how we can see a system where the
earthly kingdoms will be incorporated
rather than eliminated
is uh somewhat curious to me.
>> Um by a donkey I I really appreciate
that that summary. Um and I want to yeah
I just want to uh clarify some things
here. Uh it is not my position that the
church should assume political power in
the way that the state does. So on that
point I think we're absolutely agreed. I
fundamentally believe in the separation
of of church and state. Uh where I think
my precedent lies in separation of
church and state is the idea that there
has to be a standard that determines the
split between church and state. And what
is it? I think it's the standard that
Christ rules above both. Uh Christ rules
over the church and Christ rules over
the state. And he tells the church to uh
to govern um over its particular realm
as being the pillar and ground of truth
in society. Um and it governs over the
state in telling it to exclusively
preside over justice which is to reward
the good and punish the evil and not to
transgress those boundaries. So Christ
um himself, God gives us himself in his
word the parameters through which we can
discern what these spheres uh spheres
are supposed to do. Um the church ought
not to assume responsibilities that is
given to the state. The state ought not
to assume responsibilities that are
given to the church. And uh an
additional institution that God gives us
alongside the church and the state is
the family as well. um where you see
throughout scripture the mandate for the
family to preside over health, education
and welfare. Uh that's not something
that the state is mandated to do. That's
not even something the church is
necessarily mandated to do. Um but all
these institutions are distinct. They
are separate but they but there is some
interconnectedness. There's there's an
overlap. There's account an
accountability system between between
them all. Um and you need them all to
function in their right jurisdictions in
order for true freedom to be achieved
and in order for true flourishing to be
achieved. Um so that that's just me
trying to clarify my idea on the
separation of the governments in that
sense. Um you also made a reference to
the fact that um of of where Christ's
kingship resides where where is this? Is
there a specific location for this? Um,
and it is my firm belief uh that they
are very real and direct earthly
implications uh regarding the kingdom of
Christ. Um, and if you'll allow me,
there's a few passages of scripture here
that um, I would like to refer to to to
underscore these precise points. Um, one
of the first I'll turn to here and I
referred to it earlier. Actually, let me
start here. I'll start from Psalm 33:12.
Uh, blessed is the nation whose God is
the Lord, the people whom he has chosen
as his heritage. Right? That's the
language of scripture. 1 Timothy 6:14
and I'll read up to verse 16 says to
keep the commandment unsustained and
free from reproach until the appearing
of our Lord Jesus Christ which he will
display at the proper time. He who is
blessed and only sovereign, the King of
Kings and Lord of Lords, who alone has
immortality, who dwells in
unapproachable light, who no one has
ever seen or can see. To him be honor
and eternal dominion. Amen. Um, and then
there's a few other passages here that
we could we could refer to as well that
underscore the same um, which basically
emphasize Christ's Christ kingship. One
passage that I like to point to often,
and I did this in our last conversation
was Matthew 28, which uh, begins with
Christ giving this great commission with
the words, "All authority in heaven and
on earth belongs to me. Therefore, go
and disciple the nations, baptizing them
in the name of the father, the son, and
the holy spirit, teaching them to do all
that I have commanded you, and behold, I
am with you till the end of the age.
Right? So, there's a sense in which
Christ gives us this mandate to go and
disciple the nations on the principle on
the basis of his kingship on the on the
fact that the heavens and the earth are
under his authority. Um if if Christ did
not preside over all things, he would
not be God. Um if for God to be God, he
must be sovereign. He must rule and
reign over all things. Um, and that's
why I think this is so important because
I think to diminish the kingdom of
Christ, to merely personal salvation and
personal hearts is actually to diminish
the rule over the cosmos which he
underscores throughout scripture in both
the Old and New Testament. Um, he is a
real king, not in a metaphorical sense,
but in a real sense. He's a king of
kings. It's um, it's there's a it's a
real comparative statement. U, he is
lord of lords. That's a real statement
in real time in realms uh addressing
real nations. And so it is my firm
belief that Christ in the redemption in
his work of redemption is reconciling
all things to himself as scripture tells
us um he's reconciling all things that
belong to him. And and and I think in
the reconciliation of it all and this is
what Psalm 2 tells us, those who do not
bow will be destroyed. And I think this
is the same reference that we see in
Daniel 2 and in Daniel 7 as well. Uh and
he will reign. In fact, Daniel 7 uses
very interesting language. I'll read a
little bit here in verse 14. And to him
was given dominion and glory and a
kingdom that all peoples, nations, and
languages should serve him. His dominion
is an everlasting dominion. Not will be
an everlasting dominion. Is an
everlasting dominion which shall not
pass away. and his kingdom one that
shall not be destroyed. Right? So he
rules and reigns over absolutely
everything. And this is the ground upon
which we can have the confidence that
Christ is doing something in this world.
He is reconciling people to him. He's
reconciling nations to him. He's
reconciling the entire cosmos to
himself. Um and we can we can take
comfort in that. We can find hope there.
>> Lennox U. One of the things that you
said there was that you don't or you
believe in the separation of church and
state.
>> The concern that I have is you know some
of the professors of course teachers
like Jared Longshore out of New St.
Andrews are hosting individuals like
Timone Klene uh who spoke for national
conservatism and I'm just going to read
the headline of his YouTube video here.
The case for renouncing separation of
church and state. So they're they're
very much holding to that position of
renouncing the separation of church and
state. You know in Luke 17 uh we we read
here when asked by the Pharisees when
the kingdom of God would come Jesus
replied the kingdom of God will not come
with observable signs nor will people
say look here it is or there it is. For
you see the kingdom of God is in your
midst. Now when we spoke last time about
John 6:15 when the Jews came and tried
to make Christ uh king and actually
Christ evaded them in that text. I think
your response to that was well you know
uh it's because they were they didn't
realize the the um the extent of his
kingship. But I I think to our response
to that would be, you know, they were at
that time they is is it our position
that here they were giving Christ or
trying to give Christ everything that
they had and Christ's response was to
scorn that. Um I I think we need to be
careful in that situation because
there's a difference between Christ
being king and the kingdom being
delivered to the saints. And in Daniel
7, when the kingdom is delivered to the
saints, which is human beings, that
doesn't happen until the very end of
time. So there's a very difference
there's a great difference between
saying Christ is king and then what
we're talking about here which is saints
ruling with with authority.
Yes. Um uh I would actually affirm that
in terms of saints ruling with
authority. I think there's a sense in
which the the keys to the kingdom um
have been given to the saints. In fact I
think that's precisely the point that
Christ was underscoring in in speaking
to his disciples. their interest was in
merely establishing a Jewish kingdom.
There's a sense in which their sin was
actually the sin of thinking too small.
Um and and not recognizing that Christ
is building a real kingdom that's in
their midst. That's the language of
scripture as you read out in Luke
chapter 17. Um it's it's not going to be
crafted in the way that they think. It's
not going to be achieved in the same way
that the Roman Empire had gained their
prominence and potency. Um, this is a
kingdom that is not going to be built in
the same way that human kingdoms are
established. Um, it has very real
earthly implications. It has earthly
residence, but it is not built in the
same way that other kingdoms are built.
Um and that's and and and that's why
then I think he gives them a commission
in Matthew 28 where he is a where he
tells them to go and disciple these
nations because they belong to Christ
fundamentally belong to Christ. Um we
did talk a little bit about how and
people like to bring this up how Christ
uh sort of scorned them for wanting um
to crown him as king and there's a sense
in which they were in no position to
crown a king who was already king. I
think that's something that we should
appreciate. But then still in the book
of John, Christ stands before Pontius
Pilate and Pilate asks him, you know,
are you the king? Um, and Christ does
not does not deny it um at all. In fact,
he says, you have said so rightly,
right? So, he doesn't deny that kingship
whatsoever. Again, his language in in
the great commission is the language of
kingship. what the apostles confirm in
Colossians chapter 1 and in uh 1 Timothy
chapter 6 is that very real kingship
that has very real earthly implications
as well. Um and so there's no running
away from those verses. Um and I'd be
interested with just with some of the
verses that I'd read out just hearing
some of your understanding of how we
should interpret these verses that very
clearly speak about the lordship of
Christ in this sense.
May I jump in there with a thought?
When the Bible says, "Blessed is the
nation who serves the Lord and uh the
question is who is that nation?" That's
basically what you ask. What is
represented by that nation? Is it a
specific nation of uh let's say of a
Christian nature that is here referred
to because the gospel commission was to
go out to every single nation
and I think we can safely say that those
nations largely
uh rejected the gospel commission but a
proportion of the nations accept the
gospel commission. So no matter what
nation you go to whether it is a nation
that has Shenuism or Islam or whatever
religion as their main religion there is
a proportion of that nation that has
accepted Christianity.
In my reading of the situation that
comprises the nation of God universally
spread across every nation and kingdom
and tongue. We have a people that have
Christ thrown enthroned in their hearts
as king of kings and lord of lords and
to them his law is ultimate. When it
comes to one nation let's say a
Christian nation wanting to legislate
let's say certain parameters which are
which are divine like the ten
commandments for example.
The second table of of the decalogue is
is logical and understandable. You have
to legislate to keep law and order that
you you cannot murder and you cannot
steal and you there should be a a
respect for the hierarchy that God has
put in place honoring your father and
your mother going so far as don't even
coveret whatever uh belongs to your
neighbor. When it comes to the first
table, what do you do with people that
have different ideologies? Because if we
look at the laws of blasphemy, for
example, we are horrified when somebody
uses Jesus's name in vain.
But to someone who's not a Christian,
that would not be a parame parameter for
them to to be associated with. The same
with the fourth commandment, which is
really what we're talking about. Uh what
is your understanding about
acknowledging the authority of God
through accepting the fourth commandment
as it is legislated in the Bible and
thereby acknowledging his authority and
his kingship in your life? Can I impose
that on someone else is my question. if
uh they do not have the same view of the
lordship of Christ in their lives
because they're of a totally different
religion. That would be my question. I
can understand the second half of the
decalogue, the second table being part
of every government's legislation no
matter what religion they belong to. But
the first one is very specific. It's a
very specific deity that you have to
acknowledge and have no other god beside
him.
It's a very specific commandment not to
have any form of idolatry that negates
that premise and then to honor him and
respect him and to accept his authority
by acknowledging the fourth commandment
as well. It's a very personal choice
within this parameter. And as far as I
understand it, the nation that accepts
Christ as their king and leader is the
spiritual nation that is spread out
throughout every nation in the whole
world.
>> Yeah, I I appreciate that clarity. Um I
I would I would break it down this way.
I think that it's impossible to
understand the second table of the law
without the first table of the law. The
reason I say that is the commandment to
not murder, to not commit adultery, to
not steal, to not bear false witness,
and to not covet are all premised under
the idea that there is a God and he has
spoken.
I believe that culture flows downstream
from religion. The way a people relate
to one another, the way people go about
living their lives is always anchored on
the basis of what they worship. To bring
this to to the ten commandments, nations
that do not acknowledge that there is
only one God as stipulated in the first
commandment and that there should be no
room for idolatry, which is a consistent
theme throughout the rest of the first
table. Nations that deny this seem to
have and consistently have actually a
very low view of human life where things
like abortion and many other social
atrocities are committed. People have a
very low view of marriage uh which is
where you see fornication and all types
of adultery being rampant. People have a
very low view of private property. Um,
which people just go on stealing things
because they don't respect other
people's property. Um, lies become a
very common thread. Um, and covetousness
becomes celebrated. I mean, one of the
examples I can give to that is just the
woke world that we live in where we try
to politicize envy. Um, and and and we
even call that a good thing. But the
only worldview that can actually deal
with these problems, the only worldview
that can actually be moral uh or moral
morality is strongly enshrined is a
Christian worldview. In other words, in
order for a law to be just, in order for
a law to be good, it must come from God.
And I think that's what the first table
of the law establishes. First and
foremost, our our love for one another
is premised on our love for God. This is
what 1 John chapter 4 underscores. We're
able to love because he first loved us.
We have a framework for love because
Christ has taught us what love looks
like to him. Those who are out of order
with who God is are wholly incapable of
loving another. Like that. That's I
think that's a principle that logically
speaking we would all agree with.
Therefore, I mean Christ himself as he
gives us the law um he gives us to us as
a whole. Christ reiterates this law by
speaking about our love for God and then
our love for neighbor. Um he's he's
summarizing the law um in in that sense.
Now as as it pertains to uh to to the
fourth commandment again I think that
this is about our orientation towards
God and acknowledging that he is king.
And I think even more fundamental to
this question is it should be you know
why did God institute the Sabbath? Um
was it simply a day in which
non-activity takes place? Um why did he
give us a Sabbath? And my answer to this
question is he gave us a Sabbath as a
means to acknowledge his irreversible
rule and reign over all things. Um and
and and you see this even in in in the
Sabbath Old Testament as well. the
Sabbath in the Old Testament rather uh
where two things are fundamentally
commemorated. The first thing is
basically that God's creation has been
complete. All right? So there's a
creation ordinance here. Um and you see
this as and the other the second thing
that's commemorated is the idea that his
people have been delivered from exile or
from or from slavery. Um, and so as
Christ orders creation, he sits on the
throne on that last day to acknowledge
his irreversible rule and reign. My
pattern there is in analyzing the new
covenant and seeing what the ordinances
there at Christ's resurrection. He
essentially and effectively ushers in
this new covenant that comes in with
this new creation.
um in which whereas before we we were
basically impotent, Christ then now
makes us through Christ co-airs with
himself where now we can um exercise
real dominion because of the freedom
that Christ has now given us. We can
exercise and live in true freedom
because of what Christ has given us.
Therefore, even in the keeping of the
Sabbath, which is still a good um
cosmological ordinance that I think God
has weaved into into creation, he's
weaved it into his word. We can
acknowledge that we ought to do as he
has commanded us, which is to work for
six days, which is something people
don't often underscore, right? There's
real work that's happening over six
days. And there is a day in which we
pause to remember and reflect on the
fact that Christ is king. Which is why
on the day that we worship, which in the
new covenant is referred to as the
Lord's day, it is a day when we're not
just asleep or taking naps, it's a day
in which we reorient our worship towards
the true and living God because he rules
and reigns over everything. And
therefore, I'd say in some that the
Sabbath is effectively a symbol of
enthronement. Um that is the
acknowledgment that Christ is truly God.
Um that he's truly king, that he's truly
Lord over all. And that's why he gives
us this. And even in his commandments,
our understanding of the second table
must rely on this first table in which
we acknowledge who Christ is, who God is
as Lord over absolutely everything
>> from resources.
>> Just for clarity, will you define the
two tables for us, the verses or or at
least the the number?
>> Um, pardon me. The um
>> you mentioned the first table and the
second table. Would you define that in
your mind?
>> Sure. Just just first table of the law.
um as as initially given to Moses.
>> Which which verses do you apply to the
first table is what I'm asking?
>> Or which verses or which commandments
specific
>> ones? Which of the commandments? The
first, second, third, first, second,
third, fourth, fifth.
>> Okay. I I I I I kind of go between 1
through five and then 6 through 10. Um I
think that the the first half, which is
1 through five, underscore
um an authority. They give us an
authoritative pattern and I think that
even that commandment the fifth
commandment honor your father and your
mother is still um still resides under
that and then you've got your last
>> It wasn't a quick trick question. I just
wondered how you how you viewed them.
>> Sure. Could I could I jump in here and
ask a a little bit of a question? You
know, one of the things that you said
last time is that you believed that all
10 of the ten commandments should be
legislated.
Um, and we got into a discussion about
the Sabbath and you said that you would
probably be be probably be in favor of
blue laws, meaning Sunday laws, uh, that
type thing. And then simultaneously
this time you have said that you believe
fundamentally in separation of church
and state. And so in my mind there's a
slight and I'd like your explanation of
it because in my mind it seems like
there's a slight cognitive dissonance
there because if you are legislating
the first four commandments which is our
duty to God. How is that not
how how is that keeping church and state
separate if you know what I mean?
because uh inherently you are picking a
side then debating you know what day
you're going to actually enforce as that
day. So so there's there's this
separation in my mind.
I hope I'm explaining myself.
>> Yeah. No, no, I appreciate the question,
Alex, and it's it's it's worth me
clarifying this. The one thing I I'll
begin by saying is I think God's law is
given to to all men, and I'd even say
all institutions. I think that the
family ought to be embracing and
applying this law. This is the pattern
you see specifically in Deuteronomy 6,
one of my favorite passages. Um, I think
it ought to be given to the church. They
are the ones who preach the whole
council of of God's law as the pillar
and ground of truth. Um, and it's given
um to the state in as far as, and you
see this in Romans 13 and 1 Peter 2,
where they can reward the good and
punish the evil. Um now the way that the
the I think the law also demands the
exercise of wisdom um and an exercise of
um acknowledging
God first and foremost as the true ruler
of all things and therefore we want to
submit to him in all things. Right? So
every single aspect of creation must be
in subjection to God's law. Now, the way
that I would um iron this out
specifically with the fourth commandment
is basically a state that protects
people's freedoms to worship on one day.
Um and and so I wouldn't see it as an
actual
um like like them being the the
orchestrators of determining when that
day is. And I think more so
acknowledging the fact that they ought
to be a Lord's day. Um they ought to be
a day that people put aside to worship.
Um in which people who even work within
the state ought to go and submit to
Christ themselves. Um um ought to go and
rule their families well, ought to be in
in fellowship with a very specific local
church as individuals.
um and and they themselves as a state
also having a framework for what rest
looks like. Um, so beyond them even just
imposing something, what I'm actually
referring to is more of them being
subservient to something, uh, bowing
down, um, to God's law, where they don't
see themselves as being as one, being
the architects of God's law, even the
fourth commandment, um, but two, them
actually being subservient to God's law,
where they are themselves adhering um,
to God's law. Um and so I I think that
all the governments again ought to be
working together in the application of
God's law. And I think it's important to
underscore here that when I'm speaking
about the state imposing morality, what
I am underscoring is that God has
created this world
um God has created people, God has
created institutions to be ruled by
something. Um vacuums and gaps do not
exist.
um people will either worship God or
they will worship idols. For true
morality to really reside
and permeate and persist in any given
nation, it must be rooted in God's law.
Uh James refers to God's law as the law
of liberty. It is the foundation um of
true freedom. And so in applying God's
law in in a state that upholds God's
law, what they're actually seeking to do
is protecting people's freedom. That
like that's the only way they can
protect people's freedom. Um secularism
can never achieve freedom for people. It
can never achieve human flourishing.
It's only God's law that can enable us
to actually be free and to flourish the
way that God created. And so the way the
state does this is by um calling what
God calls good good and calling what God
calls evil evil and punishing the evil
and protecting the good um fundamentally
and all of it under the lordship of
Jesus Christ.
>> Could I um
>> sorry
>> uh let me jump in here just real quick
and then Walter and Martin I wanted to
get your kind of take on this as well.
So there was a article written by Pope
Leo I 13th in 1885 called Immortal Day
and it was an encyclical and there was a
statement here I wanted to read and I
wanted to see if you agree with it uh
Lennox or what your thoughts were about
it and then this kind of opens up a
broader discussion about um some of the
other things that Pope the 13th said. He
said hence it is and this is kind of
reading in the middle so you'll have to
forgive the lack of some context but
you'll you'll see what I'm talking
about. Hence it is divinely ordained
that he should lead his life be it
family or civil with his fellow men
amongst whom alone his several wants can
be adequately supplied. But as no
society can hold together unless someone
be overall directing all to strive
earnestly for the common good. Everybody
politic must have a ruling authority and
this authority no less than society
itself has its source in nature and has
consequently God for its author. Hence
it follows that all public power must
proceed from God. For God alone is the
true and supreme Lord of the world.
Everything without exception must be
subject to him and must serve him. So
that whosoever holds the right to govern
holds it from one soul and single
source, namely God, the sovereign ruler
of all. There is no power but from God.
Now Lennox, would you agree with that
statement because I think it echoes a
lot of what you have said so far.
Um, I would agree with what scripture
says before any attempts are made to pin
me to to Rome whatsoever.
Um, I am I do not endorse Roman theology
um or Roman Catholic doctrine
whatsoever. Uh I will say that according
to Romans 13, God has charged the state
uh with the responsibility to wield the
sword which is to reward the good and
punish the evil. Um my precedent is not
what Pope Leo would say. my precedent is
what scripture would fundamentally say.
Um and um I do think that the state is
ordained by God very specifically for
that reason because he is king of kings.
He's the one who establishes how kings
should rule. Um
>> so one of the other things that uh Pope
Leo was known for was some of his other
encyclicals. Um one of them comes to
mind is raram Novarum. And there's
there's a lot of commentary about how a
day of rest should be enforced. And of
course, this is in the 1800s. And so we
went on and we did some research and um
we found some very interesting articles
about how Sunday rest was implemented
then because it's interesting in a lot
of our conversation last time stemmed
around the Sabbath. So, I have a couple
different poster boards here that we
printed out, and I hope you'll be able
to see those. Okay, I'll read you what
they say because I'm sure you won't be
able to read it. But back in 1895,
there were several Seventh Day
Adventists who
worked on Sunday, and it went against
the state laws at the time,
>> and it made national headline news
across the United States. Um, we found
32 different newspapers,
um, all with headlines discussing 7th
Day Adventist jail. In fact, some of
them were placed in chain gangs. And I
think we mentioned that last time we
spoke. Um, so one of the one of the
things that was said here is in
Gravesville, Tennessee, about 30 miles
from Chattanooga, a 70-year-old SDA was
digging his well, working 40 feet below
ground and quote, neither by sight nor
sound, disturbed his Orthodox neighbors.
The same article goes on, HC Leachch, a
a farmer, was charged with clearing his
land, cutting brush, and doing like work
on Sunday. Lewis Abbott, a merchant, was
charged with selling goods on Sunday.
Another article states that the jury was
out 15 minutes and brought a guilty
verdict for Leech. Alan Cathy, a mere
boy, was cutting wood in the yard of his
own home on Sunday morning. Another boy,
six or seven years old, was accused with
his father of doing work on the farm on
Sunday. But when the judge saw the
little fellow and noted his extreme
youth, he ordered them basically to not
prosecute that particular case. So you
had across several different states in
1895, you had 7th Day Adventists that
were persecuted for doing work on their
own property, digging a well, not
disturbing their neighbors deep
underground. And so the the question I
have is this notion of common good that
is being spoken of um that's very
popular in today's society. The common
good would state that the majority wins,
the majority rules. And so if you go and
you start legislating the first four
commandments, again, it goes back to how
do you successfully
um how do you successfully do that and
still maintain separation of church and
state? And I know you have said, well,
everyone should have one day. But even
Douglas Wilson, James, you had a clip
actually talking about Douglas Wilson um
where he was talking specifically about
that. Let's play that clip just real
quick. I wanted to get your reaction to
this.
>> Are Christian nationalists like yourself
seeking to pass a national Sunday law
that will eventually lead to persecution
coming for those who want to observe
Saturday as the Sabbath?
>> Uh, no. I've never heard anybody
proposing that or talking about it or
wishing that they could. I do believe
that the Sabbath is going to be part of
a reformation of our morals. I don't
believe the fourth commandment has been
uh retired in any way. So, if there is a
national reformation and revival, I
believe that that will result in a
national honoring of the Lord's Day. I
do believe that that's going to happen.
This is the extent of the persecution
that I'd be willing to um deploy against
a Seventh Day Adventist. He would not be
able to go into a shop and buy a shovel.
That's how that's the extent of the
pers.
>> Right. Right.
>> That would be the extent of the
persecution.
>> Yeah. One of the things I would observe
from this is if we go back to the days
of William the Conqueror, there was a
prohibition against buying or selling on
Sunday. But there was also a prohibition
against anybody being able to buy or
sell who was found disobedient to the
apostolic sea. Now, I think one of the
things that Doug Wilson is overlooking
here is the fact that there very much is
and he has talked to multiple
individuals who are actively calling for
Sunday legislation and and we've talked
about uh everybody from Jared to Steven
Wolf to Teimone to the Naton Manifesto,
the fact that it's in Heritage uh uh
foundations uh you know project 2025.
But he's also wanting to implement
coercion at this point to where you
cannot uh buy a shovel. And there were
there were people back in the 19th
century who actually died in some cases
as a result of being prosecuted for
Sunday rest violations and being
separated from their families who lost
that support during the time of
persecution uh that that took place. And
that was actually brought before
Congress by Alonzo Jones at that time.
Um but Walter, I think you had something
a moment ago be before I spoke. I'm
sorry.
>> What I was wanting to say is there was a
reference to the new covenant
and that there were apparently, you
know, fundamental changes that came
along with the new covenant. Uh the
scripture tells us that the new covenant
is basically moving away from the letter
of the law to the substance of the law
and that God was going to write the law
into our hearts so that we do not hold
or uphold the law through uh whatever
means we deem necessary to be in harmony
with the law but from a conviction that
comes out of the heart. That is what is
meant.
But in no way did it ever imply that the
law was changed because Jesus himself
said that not one jot or one tit would
by any means disappear from the law. Now
that is not a comma or a full stop would
be removed from the law. It is
unchangeable. It would stay as it was.
And I'm hearing a lot about the Lord's
day. And I know that the position of
Rome and the position of the evangelical
world is that today the Lord's day is a
reference to Sunday.
Whereas the Sabbath of the fourth
commandment is a reference to Saturday
and uh we basically have this divide.
Which one do you accept as authorative?
Now, on what basis can the Lord's day be
defined as Sunday? Because the only
reference that we really have in the New
Testament to the Lord's day is the one
that we find in the book of Revelation
where John was in vision on the Lord's
day. But it doesn't define that it was
the first day of the week. Neither does
it detract from the fact that the Lord
is Lord of the Sabbath because the
Sabbath in in that way of thinking was
always the seventh day of the week. So
my point is if we define the Lord's day
as Sunday
with no biblical reference that it is
Sunday because Isaiah 58 clearly tells
us that the Sabbath is the day of the
Lord. There's only one definition of the
Lord's day and it's always been the
Sabbath and it's unchangeable. So what
we have is a collision of ideologies
where one regards the Sabbath
commandment, the seventh day as the
commandment of accepting the authority
of God in your life and the other one
says no we have to spend the Lord's day
which now is redefined as the first day
of the week and then you will have a
conflict of interest which led exactly
to what happened when the Blair Bill was
passed and Adventist s who chose the
seventh day according to the scriptures
were persecuted, prosecuted, put in
chain gangs. Wouldn't the same thing
happen if there were such legislation in
the future? My opinion is absolutely it
would happen. So it's not a question of
what day we're going to worship. It's a
question of whose authority is paramount
in our lives. Is the scriptural
command the one that dictates to us
which day I acknowledge as authorative
or is it uh the state together with a
church that has redefined the Sabbath as
the first day of the week?
>> Yeah, I appreciate I appreciate those
questions. Um to which I'd say I think
that what what scripture gives us is
definitely a pattern. Um, and one of the
patterns that you see throughout
scripture is the pattern of of covenants
and specific signs that accompany these
covenants. Um, and just as you said um
earlier that Christ underscores the
substance of the law, right? Like
fundamentally underscores the substance
of the law. Um, and and and he's not
seeking to do away with the law. In
fact, he he very plainly says, "I've not
come to abolish the law, you know, but
actually to uphold the law." Right? But
so what do we infer from that? And I
think uh another question that would
arise from that, people like you and me
would have answers to these sort of
questions, but would be then what do we
do with the rest of the law? Why is it
that you're able to say that Christ
upholds the law and yet there are some
practices in the old covenant law that
have been done away with? what's our
criteria with which we use to determine
what we continue to uphold um and what
we uh continue or what we consider as
accomplished and fulfilled in Christ,
right? Um so, for example, there's
there's certain tenants of the
ceremonial law that Christ has fully
accomplished because a lot of that law
was as a way to show people their need
for a savior. Right? So uh uh let me
backtrack here and speak about what uh
many people in the Protestant reformed
movement and even before then regarded
the three uses of the law. Um and and in
these three uses you see you see on one
hand the law just being a good measure
of of what helps people recognize their
own sin and their need for a savior,
right? Like they're they're those two.
Um but then also the law as being the
framework through which God enables us
to know how to love him and to love one
another. Right? So this is this is what
God gives us. And then there's also
different kinds of law that we see in
the Bible. I like to see it generally
speaking as one law, not different laws.
But I think there's good ways to
categorize them to help us make sense of
them. And so there are tenants of the
ceremonial law specifically that we no
longer
adhere to not because they have
necessarily been abolished but actually
because they've been fulfilled in Christ
through his perfect atoning work on the
cross. Um and so we acknowledge that.
And so, um, even just by your own
affirmation just now, we we still have
the substance of the law, but the way
that actually applies in contemporary
times or in the new covenant
specifically, um, is not going to look
absolutely identical. Something I should
point to here in terms of trying to
answer your question directly in terms
of which day we're supposed to worship,
which is which is a big thing. There's a
couple things here I I'd want to
underscore. Um, and that's on one hand I
think that scripture does give us the
imperative to absolutely have a day to
rest. And so I would consider the
Christian Sabbath as as paramount in
that. I think what the apostles did uh
and underscored what the early church
underscored was a commemoration of the
resurrection of Jesus Christ. Um, and
let me also backtrack here and and and
use that clip that you played of Doug.
Um, I think he's sure I think he's being
very clever with his speech here. And
um, I would say fundamentally I do agree
with what he's saying. What he's
actually saying, he's not endorsing
persecution of people who would choose
to worship on another day. But he is
saying that in a Christian nation that
recognizes the new covenant, there ought
to be a commemoration of Christ's
enthronement and his new creation that
is that was cemented in his
resurrection. And therefore, in an
understanding of that commemoration,
there ought to be a day on which people
are in worship of of God. Um, and
therefore Chick-fil-Ass all across
America are closed on a Sunday, right?
Because people are in worship of God.
Um, and so he's saying this tongue and
cheek where and Hobby Lobby, there you
go. Uh, so tongue and cheek. He's saying
that our persecution in that sense would
be that we can't enjoy an amazing
chicken sandwich on a Sunday. That's the
extent of the persecution. But I don't
think that we're underscoring the fact
that they should be this violent
persecution of people who choose to
worship on on another day. So I'd say
that and and by the way, so coming back
to what you're saying before, you're
absolutely right when you say that in
the new covenant, we're not often
explicitly underscored like a specific
day on which to worship. And I actually
that think that that means that that's
one of those distinctions in the new
covenant where we as co-airs in Christ
have
dominion even over something like time
and the way that we wisely exercise that
time. All this to say I am far less
dogmatic in terms of what specific day
we ought to worship. Um, I uphold the
Lord's day as Sunday uh for the the
pattern of the new covenant and
acknowledging Christ's resurrection as
the moment that shifted time um as a
moment that shifted the rule and
authority of the cosmos in a fundamental
way and that's the precedent. But I can
also I give room to people who would
absolutely want to acknowledge that on
on another day. Um, I think the
principle, and this is what Doug was
saying, is in a in a country or in a
nation that submits to God, they will
recognize a holy day. As the world has
become increasingly secular, there's
been a blurring of those lines. People
no longer recognize a holy day. Um, and
I think what reformation will prompt is
for people to acknowledge a Sabbath, a
Christian Sabbath, I'd say, regardless
of what that day is. But I think it it's
it it for the sake of social harmony I
would say um it's helpful when um all
people in the nation can can come
together to worship on a specific day uh
where the economy can rest whole scale
everything can rest and worship whole
scale. I think that works for social
harmony. Um, but I'd say still in
Christianity and in a true Christian
republic, people would have more
freedoms to worship uh God um in the way
that he's revealed even if they have
their own interpretations than any kind
of society, let's say a secular society.
>> So I want to ask a question about
>> the 2025
>> question. Go ahead, Walter. I said the
2025 document
uh underscores the fact that the day of
rest could be either the Sabbath or the
Sunday. No particular day is specified
but it does claim that the default is
Sunday.
Now when Constantine made a Sunday law,
he made a Sunday law which prohibited
work on the Sunday. When Catholicism
made a law uh regarding the same issue,
it added a clause which said that
Christians shall not judize. They will
work on that day. In other words, it
wasn't just a day of not being not
working on a Sunday, but a day
legislating against against
Sabbathkeeping. In other words, keeping
the seventh day of the week. And uh is
it possible do you think that a law that
starts off kind of benign
could escalate to a point where because
of nonconformity
or difference in ideology?
It could go that way and become
oppressive like it was in the middle
ages.
>> Yeah. I just want to because that can
link on to what you said that we must
remember there must be six days of work
and one day of rest and also that um
if you uh look at the economy the
economy will do good with one day of
rest but what if it happens to be now
two days of rest because now uh for
instance Sabbath keepers will keep the
Sabbath and the Sunday. So then they
start saying, "Okay, wait. Something's
not working here."
>> In fact, some of the labor laws,
particularly in Europe and particularly
some that have been in the news quite a
lot, like in Greece, for example, would
make it virtually impossible to rest on
a Sunday because of the hours that you
are permitted to work and the number of
hours that must be put into a work week.
So that the only real day that you could
have as a rest day would be Sunday. And
that would be a very similar thing to
legislating against keeping the seventh
day as the Sabbath. So it could escalate
into something like that. It might start
benign, but it can become tumerous.
>> Yeah. Um and and here's the thing. I I
actually would share a very similar
concern. Um if if if that were the case,
um I would want I would want people to
be able to worship the true and living
God um in the manner in which Christ has
ordained in scripture. And I would
within that context also invite
discussion and debate as we're having on
when that day should be. Um but I would
not make it a dogmatic thing. And I
think that to the degree to which it
becomes um a violent dogma that is
something that even I would resist.
Absolutely. Um I think um that there's
there's a principle um of religious
liberty and by religious liberty I do I
am not um referring to the validity of
pagan religions and religious liberty as
opposed to Christians being able to
worship the true and living God. um in
accordance with his word but in all the
exercise of wisdom in the application of
the law which may vary between different
Christian camps um is what I'd say. Um I
I would also just underscore here that I
think perhaps one of our fundamental
differences in this is I am not
particularly anxious about this or
concerned. Not because I do not care
about the the your liberties and your
desire to worship on a specific day. Um,
if anything, I'll be one of those who's
going to stand alongside you and
champion it um for you to worship the
true and living God um on the day that
you're convicted he ought to be
worshiped. Um, but I I just don't
believe some of what I understand the
SDA prophecies to be about the Roman
Catholics being the the great Antichrist
in this sense. I believe the Roman
Catholic Church is an antichrist but not
the antichrist in this sense. Um, and I
say this because I think that Christ is
not perplexed by this. God is not
perplexed by the Roman Catholic Church.
And by perplexed, what I mean there is
that the Roman Catholic Church have not
been able to frustrate God's plan. Have
not been able to frustrate even his
sovereignty. Um in in times past and you
see this in in history in in in in
scripture has recorded it where the the
hearts of pagan kings were in his hand.
Um he is the one who controlled the
hearts of Pharaoh. He is the one who
rose up pagan kings for the rebuilding
of Jerusalem's wall. Um all of it is
within his realm. Um he is doing
something with all of it. Uh there is no
amount of evil that is formidable
against the true and living God. Um and
that's where my hope lies. So in my
understanding of the nations being
discipled and the nations fundamentally
submitting to the lordship of
>> yes to the lordship of Jesus Christ um I
believe that even people who might
misuse Christianity to push what I would
consider unbiblical laws in the name of
biblical laws will be weeded out. Right?
In history, we've had people who have
tried to uphold racism on the basis of
of Christianity or slavery on the basis
of Christianity. Um, and so people have
misused the word of God before. People
have misused the name of Christ before.
Um, but I think that in what Christ is
working out in real time in this world,
even those who misuse him, which I think
would absolutely include the Roman
Catholics, will be weeded out. um
they're not a formidable foe against the
Christ who rules and reigns over all
things.
>> Thank you for that explanation. I you
raised some questions that I want to
bring up, but I want to go back to
something that I was I was going to ask
earlier and then Martin touched on it.
So Martin, you could feel free to clean
up my question here a little bit if if
it's not exactly what you meant.
Um
when you talk about uh
us being able to take the Sabbath and
worship on it and then abide by the law
of Sunday, that is uh directly contrary
to six days shalt thou labor, isn't it?
>> Yeah. Um I I think that Okay, there
there's two things I want to say here. I
think that the that there is a pattern
in which God has given us six days of
labor, one day of rest. Um I would also
assert the fact that there's a sense in
which uh man ought to to work from rest
and not work to rest. Um sense in which
man was made to work. And I think what
that rest does um uh through worship and
and everything that that that Christ has
has called us to do on the Sabbath is to
prepare us to then go on and exercise
dominion in the way we ought to. and
that Sunday as as I would believe it,
the Lord's day is what orients us to go
forth and do that. Um, and so I'd say
that there is that very consistent
pattern. Um, and I think that in the new
covenant, uh, that continues to be the
case. Um but there's a sense in which
and what's different in the new covenant
is
I think we have the exercise of dominion
over time in that sense rather than us
being powerless and voiceless in
speaking to it. um and or or doing with
it as we please for the glory of God
>> could I I don't know
>> just just reading Exodus 20 verse8
remember the Sabbath day to keep it holy
verse 9 six days shalt thou labor and do
all thy work so if I read this and I
keep the seventh day Sabbath and then
I'm a private business owner let's say I
own a bakery and I bake cakes okay and
um I'm forced to close my business on
Sunday. Is that not impeding upon my
free right to keep the commandment and
work six days?
>> And again, this is I think where it gets
tricky. And I think for the sake of the
harmony of all of this, it would be much
easier if um my 7th day Adventist
friends just started to acknowledge
Sunday as the Lord's day. Then that way
we wouldn't run into those kinds of
issues. But I wouldn't say it's uh it's
something that we should absolutely
>> uh be dogmatic on. Um really like I mean
it's not something I think people should
be imprisoned over or killed over um in
that sense.
>> But the fear is Linux there are people
who think that people should be
imprisoned over it.
>> Yeah.
>> It's not a fear. It's a historical
reality.
>> Bring a message from history.
>> Yes.
Well, and and here's the thing again as
I as I've underscored um I would be
right alongside you uh should that
happen.
>> Can I bring a a lesson from history
uh when you you mentioned that God is
sovereign and I absolutely agree with
you 100%.
But that doesn't mean that every ruler
that ever ruled uh acknowledged his
sovereignty. Some of them eventually
like Nebuchadnezzar came to the point
where they were uh in such a state that
they did acknowledge his supremacy.
You mentioned Pharaoh for example. Uh
God is sovereign also over Pharaoh and
he made sure that his will would be uh
would be done even in the presence of
Pharaoh. Now the one interesting thing
about the history of Pharaoh is that
Pharaoh uh legislated against the
Sabbath. Uh Pharaoh said to Moses and ye
Moses make the people rest. The word
there in the Hebrew is Shabbat. Ye Moses
make the people keep the Sabbath day.
You will work. Take away their straw.
They must collect their own straw. You
will work. So he legislated against
keeping the Sabbath. And God's answer to
that was plagues.
And he said, "Let my people go that they
can worship me and
follow my commandments." And one of the
commandments that God
drilled into the Israelites when he took
them out of Egypt was the Sabbath day.
And if you read the story of Exodus and
what happened there, the issue of how
holy the Sabbath was and how God drilled
it into them with the falling of the
mana that on the seventh day there would
be none but a miracle would be done that
it would last without seeing corruption.
And that's a reference also to the body
of Christ because he says he is the
living manner. and he rested in the
grave not seeing corruption. When he
rose on the first day, it was not to
rest but to continue the work and
preparing the disciples and working with
them. So Christ even in his death kept
the Sabbath. But my point is those that
legislated against it and made it
impossible
for the Israelites to keep the Sabbath,
they were eventually punished with
plagues. And if we if we go to the point
where we legislate a commandment and
force people to accept an ideology which
is not according to them biblical, then
aren't we in danger of following that
same road? and experiencing perhaps the
same consequences.
>> Um I would say quite the contrary. What
you see with Pharaoh is a pagan king um
seeking to impose
pagan legislation um seeking to shake
his fist at the almighty God. Um I think
that in that sense uh a nation that bows
down to Christ and Christ alone um is a
nation that will not have those kinds of
hang-ups because there will be true
freedom there. I think true freedom um
is is exclusive to Christianity um is
exclusive to Christ. Um and the example
that you give is uh is an example of
paganism. Not this is not a consequence
of of Christianity influencing nation.
That's paganism influencing a
a nation. And I think in the pattern of
history, and this has never been
perfect, at least not yet. Um is
wherever you've seen the influence of
Christianity on a nation, those nations
tend to be more free. Right?
Holistically speaking, they tend to be
more free. Uh there tends to be uh there
tends to be more justice. Um you compare
Islamic countries to Christian countries
and there's a very stark difference.
um in in in in in Christian societies,
women are more free than they are in
Islamic countries, uh there is more
freedom economically um and on on
several other metrics. And I think
that's just consistent in showing us
that uh freedom and flourishing are
exclusive to truth. They're exclusive to
Christianity. And so I think a truly
Christian nation is one where people
would be truly free. And of course,
freedom is should not be defined as the
ability to do whatever we want and more
so the the freedom to do as we were
created to do by God. Um, and I think
that the best way to safeguard this
freedom is by adhering to God's word, is
adhering to God's law. Um, and this goes
back, I think, to even creation when God
gives to Adam the commandment to not eat
of the fruit. Um, the substance of that
specific law was that Adam was not to
disobey God because Adam's liberty was
anchored and directly tethered to the
keeping of that law. For as long as Adam
steps outside the parameters of God's
law, he is no longer free. And I think
that we can take a lesson from that
principle where we can and should
acknowledge God's law as good as Psalm
119 so aptly describes to us and
recognize that goodness resides there
exclusively within the tenants of of of
God's law. And whenever we transgress
that law that's when we lose our
freedom. So, I'd say that that fear of
persecution under what is a true
adherence to God's law, um, I don't
expect that would be the case. And I
think that where it would be where where
it is the case in terms of visible
expressions of of violence, I don't
think what we're seeing there is
Christianity. I think what we're seeing
is the misuse of Christianity, the the
misuse of God's name.
Lennux, I've got a clip that I'd like to
play here from Doug again. Um, going
back to something you said earlier. Uh,
this is a clip about the pope here
because one of the concerns that, uh,
you know, I think I have is it's easy
perhaps for us to recognize Pharaoh as a
pagan ruler. But what about Antichrist
who tries to rise within the Christian
church? Let's take a look at Doug's
statement here.
>> Popes, even the Renaissance popes, even
the worst of them, didn't claim to be
God. you know, they were they would they
made grandiose claims for themselves,
but they didn't go as far as Caligula.
>> In this statement right here from
Douglas Wilson, one of the things that
he does is he mentions how the popes did
not ever claim to be God. Um, but you
know, the reality is is one of the books
that we have right here and is uh actual
canon law right here. And in distinction
96 when it talks about the pope uh satis
evident ostendtor it actually in the
Latin shows himself to be god actually
referencing a pious prince constantine
in in providing the appellation of god
to the pope. So when we talk about
paganism, my concern is that paganism
has crept into the Catholic Church. And
my concern here is that Doug Wilson and
others are not recognizing Antichrist as
the Protestants did of old in even basic
canon law where the pope was shown to be
God. And so, you know, this is the power
that Protestants recognize from Daniel
7:25
that changed God's times and laws
specifically from the 7th to the 1st.
And you know, we talked about the mark
of the beast last time. I would ask you
this, uh, because you mentioned you
thought that the mark was lawlessness.
Um, in some sense, I would agree that
the mark is definitely a violation of
God's law, but who would you say is the
beast?
>> Yeah. Um, appreciate the question,
James. And,
um, to this I'd say I don't think Doug
is actually underscoring at all that
that there's no problem with the Roman
Catholic Church. In fact, what he was
saying in that specific clip is a a a
reference to a a very specific time
period, which was the Renaissance, where
you had some popes, not the papacy as a
whole, but some popes who didn't dare um
equate themselves to God. Now, this is
not a validation of these popes. This is
not an endorsement of these popes. This
was Doug just trying to make uh a very
apt description of um the importance of
that time period and how people uh
viewed God and viewed all of life um in
light of that. Um Doug would be the be
one of the first people I know to
denounce the papacy in that sense. So
that that's not what he's saying.
um he's he is giving some credit where
it's due where there was some popes very
few not all popes have been identical in
their affirmations. I think that's
something even you would acknowledge and
that's simply um um a point he was
making. This is not him trying to uh
affiliate himself with Rome or endorse
the papacy or anything like that. Um not
at all. So one one thing that you said
is you you made the quite the
distinction um between uh Pharaoh and
said well that's a pagan that's a pagan
person entirely that's like it doesn't
relate
>> you know in March 7th 321 AD Constantine
had a statement he said all judges and
city people and the craftsmen shall rest
upon the venerable day of the sun
country people however may freely attend
to the cultivation of the fields because
it frequently happens that No other days
are better adapted for planting the
grain in the fros or the vines in the
trenches. So
you know the the thing is here this is a
pagan emperor and he's saying on the day
of the sun and the reason he's saying
that is because they worshiped soul
invictus right they were a sun
worshipping society and so why is he
having to make this edict of worshiping
on Sunday
you know this is you you see some
reference to it earlier than this but
there was a great change that took place
in centuries following Christ, you had
you have multiple examples of Paul and
the apostles going into the synagogue
and and Jesus, you know, going and as
was his custom. So, you had this this
gradually take place. In fact, in some
of these pages of these old books that
we have that are detailing this great
change that took place, there was
reference to how they were to fast on
the seventh day. And so gradually what
happened is you had
the the church basically saying,"Well,
you got to fast on the Sabbath on the
seventh day of the week, but then we'll
feast on Sunday." And so you had this
change that took place, and it was a
gradual change, but it took a couple
hundred years. And one of the the main
things that happened here was
Constantine's edict, although that
wasn't the first or the last you heard
of it. But that, you know, we have a
catechism right here that's falling
apart. Um, it's a doctrinal catechism
and this is from the 1800s. I don't know
if you can see how old that thing is.
I'm having to be very gentle with it,
but it's part of our collection here.
And they say quite clearly that they had
the power to do what no other church
could do. Um, and let me just read a
short little excerpt of it. Have you any
other way of proving that the church has
power to institute festivals of precept?
Answer. Had she not such power, she
could not have done that in which all
modern religionists agree with her. She
could not have substituted the
observance of Sunday, the first day of
the week, for the observance of
Saturday, the seventh day, a change for
which there is no scriptural authority.
So this is a doctrinal catechism. This
is what the Catholic Church says
themselves. And this is long before the
Protestant Reformation ever took place.
So my question to you is if they
themselves are saying that they changed
it, you know, going going back James,
you you mentioned Daniel 7, uh Daniel 7
verse 25. There's a power that's spoken
of there that mirrors the antichrist
power that's spoken of in Revelation. So
I believe it's the same power. There's a
power that's spoken of there that says
it will seek to change times and laws.
Okay? Now, if you look if you read
through Daniel, this is clearly talking
about after Christ's first coming. And
so, if the ceremonial law has already
been fulfilled at that point, which is
the law that was kept in the side of the
ark, so it was written in a separate
location than the ten commandments
written on stone with God's own finger.
What law remains? Well, it's only the
ten commandments.
>> And in those ten commandments, if you
seek to change times and laws, there's
only one time,
>> right? And so you have them saying,
"Yeah, we changed it." And then you have
the Bible saying, "They're going to
change it." You have Constantine saying
on the venerable day of the sun, which
is a pagan holiday, it was because it
was soul invictus. They start
worshiping. So to your point about
Pharaoh, right, you said Pharaoh was a
pagan, you know, pagan monarch
basically. Well, Constantine was. I do.
Do Do you see my point at all?
>> Yeah. Here's the thing. I'm I'm not I'm
I will not defo I will not defend Roman
Catholic doctrine. Um and to the degree
to which it's erroneous, yeah, we should
absolutely throw it out. Um so that's
that that's not my bone of contention at
all as a uh as someone who is Protestant
and and and reformed. Um I think that we
should want to see God's law applied in
the way that is clearly articulated in
his word. Um, and I think that something
else that I think I should mention here,
Alex, is
um, I think over time there's been all
kinds of debate over law. Um, even the
Pharisees, for example, who are trying
to pin Jesus on his, uh, seeming
violations of the law. Um, and they were
very hung up on a specific day and what
ought to happen on that day. U there's a
sense in which what they were trying to
implement was not actually God's law but
what but their own um subjective
opinions of what piety were that that
wasn't truly truly God's law but of
course they were doing it in the name of
God's law and because they did that they
were really binding people's consciences
um and these kinds of things were a
problem in the early church you even
kind of see the apostles dealing with
these kinds of things where people want
to impose cert certain Jewish customs um
that didn't actually have anything that
pertains to salvation or even with the
the fundamental life and doctrine of the
church. Um and so again, there's all
kind of quibbles over over days. Um and
this is not to say that days aren't
important or that pagan kings seek to
undermine time in the way that God has
has has set it forth. Yeah, we should
denounce paganism wherever we see it.
Um, but I think even more so, we should
appreciate the fact that God is still
the one who rules over time. And as
co-airs with God, there's a sense in
which we have the ability to redeem time
in that sense and to exercise it in the
way that God has called us to exercise
it. So, I mean, Alex, I mean, I know
that you're you're trying to tie this
back uh to uh Constantine and and the
Roman Catholic Church. I'd say that uh
maybe what you're coming down to here is
you know like do you not see that
they're the ones who kind of changed
everything to which I'd say no. Um there
there documents that exist even before
uh Constantine um documents that that
exist before the Roman Catholic Church.
Um that that suggest that the Lord's day
was recognized on the first day of the
week. I mean I can think of the dedicay
for example. Um, I can think of uh
documents around it um that that that
pointed to that. Um, and of course there
there's a few passages in the New
Covenant as well that make these
references uh to new covenant language,
the Lord's supper, the Lord's day. Uh,
something clearly has changed in light
of the resurrection of Jesus Christ.
There is a new creation. There is a a
new world order. Uh there is a new
sheriff in town. There is a new
authority. Um and whereas before people
would have been very dogmatic on some
things, there's a sense in which the new
covenant um actually offers more freedom
in that sense. It offers a greater
exercise of wisdom in upholding God's
law. Um yeah, so those are my comments
on that. If if I can add something to
what was said about that statement in
the catechism
when it came to the divide between
Catholicism and Protestantism
at the council of Trent. This discussion
revolved around what was the authority
that should guide us and the position of
the Protestant was that the scriptures
was the sole guide of our moral duty
towards God. And the Catholic tradition
was added to this. So the Catholics said
that the scripture in the framework of
tradition should determine what our
obligation towards God is. And this
divide was unbridgegable.
And eventually it came to the point
where the archbishop of Hio stood up in
the council of Trent and stated that
Protestantism was basically just a
rebellion and that he could prove it
because the scriptures clearly outlined
the keeping of Saturday as the Sabbath
and the Catholic Church had changed it
to Sunday. So by acknowledging the first
day of the week, he claimed that they
were acknowledging the authority of the
Catholic Church and denying their solar
scriptura.
And on the point of that basis,
Catholicism was able to uh say that
Protestantism was not a religious
movement per se, but nothing more than a
rebellion against church authority.
And this was a perfect timing where
Protestant could could have said well
yes we do acknowledge solar scriptura
and actually you have a point because
there is no scripture that definitely
tells us that there has been a change
from the seventh to the first day of the
week but they didn't they stuck to it
and today within the ecumenical council
and with the charter ecommenica they
have again acknowledged some form of
supremacy of the papal sea. And if that
is the position of the papal sea, then
it means that you are acknowledging the
authority of an earthly institution
rather than a divine institution.
And therefore, it becomes a very moral
choice. Am I acknowledging the authority
of an earthly institution which is which
is culminated in the papacy and broadly
accepted within the ecumenical movement
or am I acknowledging the authority of
God. So it's not just a question of a
day. It's a question of whose authority
is nomminative in your life. And that's
why the seventh day is so pivotal to the
seventh day Adventists because this is
the issue. They still recognize the
papal system as the antichrist system
because it legislates against the
government of Christ. I just want to ask
so inside here you you mentioned that
the new covenant
uh that the Lord's day is in there and
that we should keep the Lord's day but
where um you can correct me if I'm wrong
but I if I'm correct if in thinking that
or no from what I know is that the
Catholic Church is the one that started
calling Sunday the Lord's day.
>> No, that's actually not right.
Okay. But what scriptures do you use to
s to prove that the Lord's day is
Sunday?
>> Yeah. So, so here's the thing. Um, uh,
you know, there's a few scriptures I
want to pull out here. Actually, I can I
can read them out as a
as a reference. And I want to underscore
here as well because I think uh this
needs to be said very specifically. I am
not hung up on a specific day. To kind
of illustrate this, if there's a country
in some part of the world that decides
to to to uh to observe Wednesday as a
Christian Sabbath,
um I think that's well and good, right?
So, I'm not hung up on a very specific
day. Um but I do think that there is a
pattern um that that obser that is
observed. Um and you you see this in
several kinds of gatherings. Um you see
this in Acts 20 um a reference to a
gathering on the first day of the week
right to break bread. So the breaking of
bread which is a which is a very
specific divine ordinance
>> um is is in this is happening in
covenant fellowship with God's people um
and and you see this being observed on
that day. Um 1 Corinthians 16 as well
makes a very s similar reference. On the
first day of the week each of you is to
put something aside. Um, this is a
reference to when God's people in this
time would gather in fellowship with one
another. Um, and there's another passage
here I need to find in in Revelation
that actually makes use of that specific
term, the Lord's Day. Uh but even beyond
these passages in the New Testament um
you see letters that were written in the
early church that predated the inception
of the Roman Catholic Church
specifically the dedicay um which would
highlight when people would meet and
which day of the week that was it. The
reference the Lord's day was a reference
the first day of the week. This predated
the Roman Catholic Church. Now I say
this to sort of uh to assert a pattern
that we see as distinct in the new
covenant. Um which I think is important
to underscore. Um and I'll also say this
as well is some people can get hung up
on the observation of days. For example,
the Pharisees who actually would have
agreed with you as seventh day
Adventists in terms of which day that
ought to be. Um they would change that
at all. And yet their hearts were
hardened. So I put less on a premium on
what day uh uh people place an emphasis
on. It is possible to observe whatever
kind of religious rituals and specific
times in which people uh think is right
to worship. And yet people can be
absolutely wrong. Um, and people can, as
as as Matthew tells us very profoundly,
people can prophesy in the Lord's name
and do all kinds of things in the Lord's
name and still be far away from God. Um,
and I think the same thing is true even
as we emphasize days is sometimes we can
bind people's consciences
and and make it come across that if if
if they don't observe worship on a
specific day that they are in fact
anathema. um when in fact we're saved by
grace um uh through faith alone. Um and
that's what enables us to keep the law.
We don't keep the law in order to attain
faith um in that sense. Um and so I
again I'm I'm less dogmatic about a very
precise day, but I am in keeping with
what I consider a a consistent pattern
to be. But it is a pattern I am not
going to be dogmatic about. Um, if
brethren seek to gather together on on a
Saturday and observe that as their
Christian Sabbath, well and good. Um, I
am satisfied with the fact that they are
observing um, a Sabbath at all. Um, and
if it's another day for another group of
people, well and good. Um, I think I
think that's well within their domain to
navigate wisely and still in keeping
with God's pattern of scripture.
>> So, that's almost sounding like uh,
freedom of religion.
But you said but you bring it back that
so it's actually just freedom in
Christian religion.
>> Yes. Which is the only true religion.
>> Now when when the evangelicals talk
about a day of rest and the Roman
Catholics
and the big Sunday movements in the
world like the Lord's day alliance or
the European organizations dealing with
this they are talking about a
synchronized day of worship.
because that would bring the whole
family together.
If for example, one in the family wants
to keep the Sabbath on a Saturday
and the other one says, "No, I'm going
to work on that day and the other one
wants Sunday." That would not be a
synchronized day for the family to be
together. So basically when you break it
down the only way in which you could
have a univers universal synchronized
day of rest would be to legislate
Sunday.
There was would be no other way because
if anyone chose another day it would not
be a synchronized day. So that would
bring those that adhere to the seventh
day Sabbath with those that adhere to
the first day of Sabbath into a conflict
of interests. So would it not be safer
to allow worship according to one's
conscience rather than than dictating it
by legislation?
>> Yes, that's that's exactly what I'm
asserting here,
>> Linux. So I wanted to address a couple
of the scriptures you mentioned you know
Acts 20:7 even Roman Catholicism
interestingly in 1895
uh said pointed out themselves that
Protestants who used that text to defend
Sunday rest were suicidal. They actually
pointed out how in Acts 2:46 the
disciples broke bread daytoday. But even
if you look at Acts 20, if you go on the
very next morning, which would have been
a Sunday morning, measuring even to
even, uh, Paul's out catching a ship to
Assos Sunday morning, and doing commerce
and and not resting on the day. I mean,
if the Christian nationalists had their
way, they probably would have put the
ship uh fellow in
giving him a fine or put him in jail.
But Paul's out catching a ship to Asus.
Now you mentioned 1 Corinthians 16, but
you know if I go to the mckta uh one of
the things that I find in uh Jewish
history was that they actually set aside
money from the first day of the week as
a preparation for the Sabbath. So 1
Corinthians 16 is actually flipped on
its head to Paul advocating for
preparation for when he comes from the
very first day of the week. I know
Douglas Wilson talks about that being
like a first day Sabbath. But if you go
back to 1899 in the Methodist Review,
they wrote an article must syntax die
that the Sabbath may live actually
warning their people specifically
against and these were Sunday keepers
specifically against Douglas Wilson's
argument on 1 Corinthians 16 with the
admonition publish it not in Gath. Tell
it not in the streets of Battle Creek,
lest the daughters of the sabotarians
rejoice, lest the daughters of the
Satterarians triumph. specifically
commenting how in texts like Leviticus
23:15,
you had the Sabbath going to uh week in
the LXX or you had other uh multiple
other texts throughout scripture
establishing in fact even if you go to
the Vulgate for example uh you had
different psalms for each day of the
week reflected as the first day of the
week, the second day of the week, the
third day of the week and so on. So the
evidence that and and they warned their
people that that kind of an argument was
fool's gold against the Sabbath. But uh
Douglas Wilson today uses that same
argument that Sunday keepers warned
their people about in terms of 1
Corinthians 16. You also mentioned the
dedicay and one of the things that I
want to mention about that is if you go
to the CEX H and I actually have a a
photo of that right here plate 9 folio
8A of the CEX Hiro Silitanus there's no
ham in the text. So Lightfoots actually
translated it as Lord's day when many
other people have uh remarked how it
could be according to the Lord's
doctrine or according to his example or
teaching as what dedicay actually means.
Now if you go through yes there are some
evidences in the early church that
Sunday crept in. But if you look at at
the context of that, it's very much from
some of the pagan gnostic influence. For
example, the eighth day influence from
uh or or eighth heaven if you will uh
from Plleonism
or even in some cases Gnosticism or even
the Nicicoatans. You can see examples of
this being talked about by Irenaeus or I
believe the other one might be
victoriinus of PTA. But uh so there was
influence affecting the early church and
this was creeping in. There's abundance
of evidence that the Sabbath was
continued to be remembered much longer
in the east than the west where they
apostatized first, but it was kept for
quite a while. So I don't see the
scriptural evidence there in 1
Corinthians 16 or Acts 20 actually
supporting the position but actually
defending the Sabbath position quite
quite a bit more strongly uh for resting
on the seventh day.
>> Yeah. So again, James, and I I
appreciate I appreciate get you getting
into all of that. Um yeah, I mean, on
one hand, I think you've already
acknowledged here that even in the
dedicay, there were some examples of
people who did recognize um Sunday um as
as their day of worship. And again, I'm
not super hung up on uh on what day this
is. Um, I I do think, and this is a
question I think I'd throw at you,
brothers, so as not to um impose uh my
understanding of of your beliefs on you,
but in the way I understand it, um, it
seems to me that many 7th Day Adventists
really place a very high premium on this
specific day. um as if it has salvific
ramifications which would be a very
serious concern for me. Um which is then
my question is is is it possible for
someone to be in right standing with God
in a salvific way having not observed
the seventh day as a Sabbath?
>> Well, I would ask you the question about
any other commandment in God's law. Can
somebody remain in salvific uh uh
condition if they are knowingly
willfully violating any other
commandment in God's law? For example,
adultery or anything else? You know,
we've talked about the ten commandments
here and the importance of teaching the
nations of them of that's where all the
prosperity comes from in the first table
of the law. Um but doesn't it matter
then how accurate that that we actually
pay attention to that first table of the
law? I mean, if that is so important and
it affects everything else downstream,
then how much more important is it that
we pay attention to how that first table
of the law is actually defined?
>> Exactly, James. I'd actually say that
that's the logical that would be the
logical questions to follow up like we
should we could apply God's law to
absolutely everything. Um, in in that
sense, like this is the question. Um,
but but then but it still comes back to
my question. My question really is valid
is how does man gain right standing with
God? Um and and to kind of accelerate
this,
we all fall short of the glory of God as
as as Romans 3 aptly tells us. We have
all violated God's law. Every single one
of us except Jesus Christ. So how is it
that we can have right standing with God
as lawb breakakers?
The Bible says that the time of
ignorance, God winks at. And Paul makes
it uh quite clear in his writings that
if you grow up with within a system
where you are not accustomed to the
rights and regulations that the Bible
gives us, then nature will teach you
what is right and what is wrong. So if
you are under the law, in other words,
you you know the parameters, then you
are judged by the law. But if you
violate the principles that are by
nature implanted into man, you also
violate against God's law.
>> Yeah. I think a question I'd add a
question I'll add for you there is, you
know, the thief on the cross as Christ
pronounces that on this day he would be
with him in paradise. What's the basis
upon which that thief who lived quite a
lawless life could have been said to
have been in paradise with Christ?
>> Well, it didn't say that he would be
with him on that day because Christ on
his resurrection stated that he had not
yet been to the father and that was the
first day of the week. So basically that
verse says that he would be with him in
paradise but not particularly on that
day. Verily, verily, I say unto you
today, you will be with me in paradise.
Or verily, verily, I say unto you, today
you will be with me in paradise.
>> Okay, so agreed there. But just what's
the basis for Christ pronouncing
a very real
communion with this thief on the cross?
What is that the basis for that?
>> That person was saved by the
righteousness of Christ. Amen. And and
all of us are saved by the righteousness
of Christ. Nobody is saved by keeping
the law. But Paul clearly says that uh
we are saved by grace. Do we thereby
make void the law? God forbid. He says
in Romans chapter 3, we uphold the law.
Now the Sabbath commandment is the only
commandment that identifies God as the
creator. I the Lord created the earth in
six days and rested on the seventh day.
And so heaven and earth are his
jurisdiction. So it has basically the
entire seal of authority. I the Lord
Yave the creator and the jurisdiction
heaven and earth. And it is this law
which gives the authority of the entire
law to the entire system that is
supposed to obey it. If the United
States wants to verify or ratify a law,
they also have to put a seal on it. I
the president,
that's my authority, the name of the
president and the jurisdiction, the
realm of the United States. That gives
power to the law. Without the Sabbath,
the Ten Commandments could have been
given by anyone. But the Sabbath makes
it very specific that it is the creator
God. And the first commandment makes it
very specific that that creator god is
the one that took the children out of
Egypt and brought them into uh the
promised land. So the fourth commandment
doesn't save you. You're not saved by
keeping the fourth commandment, but
because you acknowledge him as your
creator and your lawgiver. You keep the
commandment. You're not saved by keeping
it. You're saved by the righteousness of
Christ. Because we are all have sinned
and fall short of the righteousness of
Christ. And we have all sinned and
therefore none of us can boast of
anything. So we all agree in the
Protestant thinking that you are saved
by grace and grace alone and that it is
by faith in Christ's atoning blood that
you can have access to the kingdom of
God. But that doesn't negate the law. Do
we thereby make void the law? God
forbid. We uphold the law. That's why
it's so important to a seventh day
Adventist to acknowledge his authority.
And and he says this quite plainly in
the scriptures. He says, "Verily, my
Sabbath you shall keep
because it is the sign that I am the God
that sanctifies you. I am the God that
gives you my righteousness."
So, it's not a law to be saved. It's a
consequence of being saved.
>> Yes, I agree. Yeah. Go on. If
>> I can piggy back off of that just
briefly, you know, in Revelation 14:12,
there's a verse that says, "Here is the
patience of the saints. Here are they
that keep the commandments of God and
the faith of Jesus." Lennox, I think
that you're feeling like our only focus
is here is on the fourth commandment.
And you know, there's a great emphasis
placed on it because I think that you
actually would probably agree with us
wholeheartedly on the other nine. It's
not like you believe or we believe that
you can take the Lord's name in vain or
that you can go covet your neighbor's
property or that you can steal or murder
any of the rest. I think we all agree on
that.
>> Well, let's be clear. The word can isn't
appropriate there. You can do those
things, but whether we should as
>> right
>> Jesus is Lord and King of our life, we
shouldn't,
>> right? So, so we we agree that they are
sin. Um, but you know, if you go to
Hebrews
4 and verse 8, for if Jesus had given
them rest, then would he not afterward
have spoken of another day.
There therefore remainth a rest to the
people of God. So, if if you go up
Hebrews 4:4, for he spake in a certain
place of the seventh day on this wise,
and God did rest the seventh day from
all his works. And in this place again,
if they shall enter into my rest. So
then you drop down verse 8 and he says,
"Would he not then have spoken of
another day?" So if he if Paul here is
speaking and saying, "Wouldn't he have
told you of another day if you were
supposed to keep another day?" I mean,
how else how else do you read that?
>> Well, I think the context here is very
important, Alex. And of course, what the
Sabbath is trying to communicate um as a
whole. On one hand, it's it's about in
the enthronement of of Christ as as king
um as ruling time and absolutely
everything in the cosmos, but it also
points to an eternal rest, which is
really the context of of this passage
very specifically. The the Sabbath being
um um a means for us to reflect and
meditate on this eternal rest that is to
come. Um and so I think that the
emphasis here is less on on on one
specific
day um as much as it is this pattern of
creation that God has given us in which
rest is an integral part in which
worship as is an integral part. And the
emphasis here and I think this is one of
the most important ones is in verse 7 um
that that that that quote of you know
today if you hear his voice do not
harden your hearts. Um this was a
hardness of heart for people who did not
believe their whole scale were rejecting
Jesus Christ. Even though the Sabbath
had been given to them, things had been
given to them to point to this eternal
rest that's exclusively found in Christ,
people would still reject it. And so
these are people who are acquainted with
the the terminology and the practice of
Sabbath and yet their hearts were
absolutely hardened. Um the the
reference here is less to people who
just whole like whole scale didn't
observe the Sabbath. Uh these were
people who are aware which is why the
author of Hebrews could use this
specific terminology and saying like you
have this sign, you have this practice,
you're familiar with it, but your hearts
are hardened towards the Lord. Um you
you you you live in you you currently
live in a state of perpetual
disobedience and unbelief. In fact, the
the ground of that disobedience is their
unbelief. And I think this is what the
author of Hebrews is underscoring. I
don't think this is a passage to try to
um give some apologetic for like like a
specific day in the framing of of of
much of our conversation and more about
how this is pointing to Jesus Christ and
exposing the unbelief of those who
actually kept these Sabbath ordinances
and still persisted in a hardness of
heart.
>> Can I just ask a question, Lenox? Um, do
you see the Sabbath and the Lord's day
as as two different things or do you say
that the Sunday is Sabbath?
>> Um, I now say that the that the Lord's
day is the Christian Sabbath.
I think that's distinct from the old
covenant for sure. I think the seventh
day of the week was certainly uh the
Sabbath then, but I think in the new
covenant there is a new Sabbath, so to
speak.
>> Okay. So, so when Revelation says that
from one Sabbath to another we'll keep
Sabbath in heaven, you mean that that
will be the first day of the week, not
the
>> It could be it could be any day of the
week, but I'd like to believe that in
throughout the throughout the pattern, I
would I would I would generally fall on
Sunday.
>> Okay.
>> It it feels like that's ambiguous. And
and let me go back to our discussion
earlier with the table of the
commandments, the first the first five.
I may not touch on all five of them, but
we'll we'll get to a few of them. And
I'm going to read these because I
recognize that we've got two or three
podcasts represented here. And I at
least know from my podcast that I have
many folks watching from all over the
world who are not Seventh Day
Adventists. And so I think this is of
value if you guys will indulge this for
a moment. Uh Exodus 20 where we find the
Ten Commandments. I like to include
verse two. I hope it's okay with
everybody. Um because I think it's
important for all of us to know when we
leave sin, God has brought us out of
bondage. Can we say amen?
>> Amen. Verse two says, "I am the Lord
your God who brought you out of the land
of Egypt, out of the house of bondage.
Why am I giving you these commands?
Because I love you and I want to tell
you a better plan." It wasn't so much of
a command as it was, "Let me help you
live with me again." That's how I look
at the commandments. Verse three, the
first, you shall have no other gods
before me. We're pretty clear in
agreement about that. You shall not make
for yourself a carved image any likeness
of anything that is in heaven above or
that is in the earth below or that is in
the water underneath the earth. You
shall not bow to them nor serve them.
For I the Lord God am a jealous God. The
specificity which with which he makes
that no other gods,
no false gods and particularly when he
uses the term I am a jealous God. God is
very specific visiting the iniquity the
sins of the fathers upon the children to
the third and fourth generation of those
who hate me. showing mercy to thousands
to those who love me and
keep my commandments. You shall not take
the name of the Lord your God in vain.
There's the third. For the Lord will not
hold him guiltless who takes his name in
vain. There's a lot of discussion about
both a specific word against the name of
God exclaiming, "Oh God," and also if we
are Christians wearing a badge of
salvation, are we taking his name in
vain when we sin? And others see that.
So we could talk about that in in in
other circles. But here, remember the
Sabbath day to keep it holy. This is the
fourth commandment. This is verse 8 of
Exodus chapter 20. Six days you shall
labor and do all your work, but the
seventh day is the Sabbath of the Lord
your God. In it you shall do no work.
I'm going to jump down to verse 11. For
in six days the Lord made the heavens
and the earth, the sea, and all that is
in them. We're talking about the worship
of our creator, God, and rested in in in
his creation. And he rested the seventh
day. Let me read that verse 11 again. I
I kind of uh mixed it up there. For in
six days the Lord made the heavens and
the earth, the sea, and all that is in
them, and rested the seventh day.
Therefore, the Lord blessed the Sabbath
day and hallowed it. Very, very specific
about the creator. 60 six days you shall
labor and do all your work. Again, very
specific about um following the
commands. God is specific.
And how how
Lennox, I went to a a high school that
was not a Seventh Day Adventist school.
I I I went to a private school that was
Christian and I had a lot of different
faiths at the high school that I went
to. Um, it was a Christian high school.
It wasn't an Adventist high school is
what I wanted to say. And I can remember
having the discussion with one of the
teachers about, well, you know, it's
it's, you know, it's just long important
as long as you worship. But that's not
the God that I that I that I follow here
as I look at these commandments or as I
look at these guidelines for my life to
be better and connected with him. He's
not ambiguous. Look at the many things
throughout the uh sanctuary service.
He's not ambiguous about that. Look at
the journey with uh uh uh the prophet
telling non go and dip. How many times
did he get healed on the first time, on
the second time, on the third time? On
the fourth time, on the fifth time, on
the sixth time. No, he received healing
when he followed the specificity of God
on the seventh day. So I I I struggle
with this ambiguity about the change to
the first day of the week. I do not see
remember the first day to keep it holy.
I don't see that.
>> Yeah. So what I'd say to this is
basically that this was a real passage.
It's something that God gave to his
people. But God has said so much more
than this. Um, and I'd be interested in
getting your understanding on, for
example, um, Colossians chapter 2, uh,
16. Therefore, let no one pass judgment
on you in questions of food and drink or
with regard to a festival or a new moon
or a Sabbath. These are a shadow of the
things to come, but the substance
belongs to Christ. Right? So you see
here new covenant uh context here, new
covenant language speaking about types
and shadows, the fulfillments of certain
things. Um the Sabbath being something
that's instructed, but there's something
that's definitely changed here. Um and
um I'd just be interested in knowing how
you understand this specific subject.
How do you reconcile this to the grand
scheme of scripture? My reconciliation
is basically the fulfillment of Christ's
work and specifically a new
administration in this new covenant that
Christ has ushered in. Um that's that's
my flow here. Um and trying to uh read
all these passages that pertain to
Sabbath which are very specific but then
you come across uh passages like this
and you think okay what does this
actually mean here?
Well, what when you go to the to that
particular verse, it's also very
important what translation you are going
to use.
If you stick to the King James version,
then it talks about Sabbath days plural.
When it comes to some of the the more
modern ones, then it will have a
Sabbath. But uh that verse has to do
with the ceremonial Sabbaths because
it's talking about eating and drinking.
In other words, the the food sacrifices,
the sacrifices that went along with the
ceremonial law and the specific Sabbath
days, which were ceremonial Sabbaths and
not the Sabbath day. And then it says
these were a shadow of things to come
but the substance of them is Christ. So
they pointed forward to the coming of
Christ. So if you take one of those
particular Sabbaths plural lowercase
Sabbaths then you could say any one of
the feast days uh let's take the
Passover. It pointed, it was a shadow of
a greater reality. It pointed to the
coming of Christ, the Passover lamb that
would have all the parameters of the
Passover lamb. Not a bone would be
broken. It it showed the the fulfillment
in the Messiah. They were shadow laws
pointing forward. But the Sabbath is not
a shadow law pointing to the substance
which is Christ in the future. It points
back to creation. And if you go to the
book of Deuteronomy in chapter 5 where
the law is reiterated, there's another
version there of the Sabbath where it
says six days shall you labor, but the
seventh day is the Sabbath. And then it
has the same wording, but the the 20 in
in Exodus 20 it says because the Lord
created in six days, but in Deuteronomy
it says because the Lord took you out of
Egypt.
So the Sabbath day, the seventh day
Sabbath has a double parameter. It
reminds us of who our creator is and it
reminds us who our reccreator is. He
takes us out of Egypt. He restores us.
He gives us his cloak of righteousness.
So it is the day of of creation and the
day of restoration.
Whereas the shadow laws of the shadow
Sabbaths were shadows pointing to a
greater reality fulfilled in Christ. And
those laws were abolished and nailed to
the cross.
>> And remember that the law, the ten
commandments were written by God's
finger and he gave it to Moses. Moses
broke it the tables when he saw the
apostasy. Then he went back up the
mountain and again God wrote it with his
finger. the other laws, the ceremonial
laws, God instructed Moses, but he wrote
it on a piece and that was
>> the book of the law.
>> The book of the law and would put on the
side of the ark of the covenant. Inside
the ark of the covenant was the ten
commandments and that Sabbath is
insconed in there where the ceremonial
ones was on the side of the ark. And
above the ten commandments, there was
the mercy seat, the hilarion,
which is basically the atonement, the
the shielding from the condemnation of
the law. It pointed to Jesus Christ who
would shield us from the condemnation of
the law by taking the condemnation upon
himself and dying the death that was due
to me. So that law was placed within the
ten commandments and its condemnation
which was which comes to all of us was
basically absorbed by Christ and he paid
the price. But the book of the law was
placed beside the ark and it was there
as a testimony against us because it
told us the remedy for sin. The remedy
of sin always remained Jesus Christ.
There is no remedy. I cannot be saved by
keeping the law. I cannot a dead man
cannot tie his own shoelaces.
I need someone who has life within
himself who can give a dead man life
again. And uh if you go to John uh the
first chapter, it in the beginning was
the word and the word was with God and
the word was God. By him were all things
made and without him was not anything
made that was made. In him was light.
Life and this life was the light of the
world. He's the lightbearer. He's the
living one who had the life in himself.
And that is what it's all about. Who is
this creator God? Who is the one that
made everything? Who is the one that
redeemed us? And then that sad voice he
came unto his own and his own received
him not. Must be the saddest voice verse
in the entire scriptures. The point is
do I acknowledge him him as my creator
and as my redeemer and in my
understanding the Sabbath is absolutely
pivotal for that relationship.
>> It is. And yet some of the people that
Jesus in fact many of the people Jesus
engaged with were people who kept the
Sabbath
>> but their hearts were still hardened. So
the keeping of the Sabbath
>> had no actual bearing for for how they
do things.
>> Um and then again just coming to
Colossians 2 the terminology here is you
know therefore no one is to act as your
judge or um let no one be judged for
very specific things as it pertains to
Sabbath. In other words, like this is
actually one of those things that I
think scripture is is shedding more
light on the Sabbath and giving us
something that's very distinct in the
new covenant, which is underscoring some
of our freedoms. Um, and there's this
very specific reference to Sabbath in
this context as something no one should
judge you over regarding a festival, a
new moon, or a day. In other words, um
to traditions in the way things have
been done before. Um that that that's
what the the reference to new moon here.
It was the new moon which was a a Jewish
festival.
>> Um ceremonial drinks and um yeah um
things that were very particular to that
time. And Sabbath is included in this
specific thing as something that
shouldn't bind the consciences of people
in terms of one specific tradition as it
had been continued before. Um and so yes
and amen to everything that you'd said
about how Christ fulfills it all. He
fulfills the law on our behalf. His
righteousness um in justification is
imputed to us. Um and um as he gives us
new life, he is making us more like
himself in that sense. Um but there's
also a real a real metaphysical
shift in the universe in the cosmos as a
result of his resurrection and as a
result of this work which I think
includes the Sabbath in a very real way.
Um where there's a pattern that's still
upheld. Um and I think that the silence
in a sense in of of the of the New
Testament by and large in relation to
this um is actually very telling about
the new covenant and the new freedoms
that we have there. On almost every
other commandment there is an
underscoring of each and every single
one. When there's rel when there's when
there's references to Sabbath you get
passages like this. Um, Romans 14 is
another passage just like it in which we
ought not to be binding people's
consciences to just one type of way of
thinking, especially as it had been done
before. Um, there is real freedom in
this sense.
>> So, can I ask
>> Go ahead, Martin.
I just wanted to ask in the portion I
think you mentioned it last time as well
where uh I think Paul preached on the
Sabbath and then there were non there
were Gentiles there and they listened
and they asked and they said okay please
next Sabbath come and preach to us
again. Um, isn't that a very clear
indication that even the Gentiles knew
that they had to come and do the seventh
day Sabbath with the rest of them?
>> I wouldn't say that that's the point of
the passage. I think that's just the
pattern of how things were done. I don't
think that's a passage that's giving
absolute injunctions. Um, it's more
descriptive of something that happened
as opposed to prescriptive in terms of
what ought to happen. Um, so the
Gentiles could recognize that and it
wouldn't have been wrong for them to
have done it at all. Um, I think what
would be wrong is trying to to bind
Gentiles um to the traditions of the
Jews that went beyond the ordinances of
the new covenant. Um um and and there's
some real distinctions there.
>> Could I raise uh one verse that I wanted
to kind of get your take on? Um, you
know, there's a a verse here in Numbers
23:20,
and it says, "Behold, I have received
commandment to bless, and he hath
blessed, and I cannot reverse it." We
also know that when Jacob and Esau
uh were born as twins,
you know, the birthright is stolen
basically for a a pot of porridge,
right? And he goes into his father and
he gets the blessing. And later, Esau
goes in and tries to get the same
blessing and there's no blessing to be
had. So the question is when God blesses
something,
can he reverse it? Because he blessed
the Sabbath day, he blessed the seventh
day. So did he reverse that blessing and
say, "Ah, actually seventh day,
Saturday, yeah, it's no longer blessed.
It's no longer holy." Because that's not
scriptural precedent, right? I think I
think the way to understand this would
be to understand the covenants and what
God is fulfilling over time. Um, Adam
falls into sin and God pronounces that
there is going to be a seed that is
going to crush the head of the serpent.
Um, and despite man's failings over time
because he is now a fallen being, God is
keeping covenant with his people. He is
actually preserving a very specific
bloodline, so to speak. and all of that.
The Lord sovereignly and providentially
ordains all of it. So I think that what
Christ is pointing to even as in
relation to to blessings is to him
keeping covenant with his people and of
course them keeping covenant with him.
Um and Deuteronomy spells this out. Um I
think it's 27 and 28. some of the
blessings of of of fulfilling the
covenant and some of the consequences of
not fulfilling the covenant of of their
disobedience. But all of it is in
relation to God keeping covenant with
his people for their redemption over
time. And that's exactly what the old
covenant, the Old Testament specifically
um fleshes out over time until the
culmination of the coming of Christ. And
before that time in his dealings with
people, he is showing things, revealing
things about himself um in in how he's
working this out. Um and so um even in
the passage that you're pointing to,
Numbers 23, I think that's exactly what
we're seeing as well. This reference to
God keeping covenant. And this is a
covenant of grace. It's a covenant that
is salvific. Um, it's a covenant um that
is ultimately going to be redemptive and
it's going to be a holistic redemption
um where Christ reconciles all things to
himself uh where man can once again live
the way that he was created to live. Um
and I and I think that's the the point
and the emphasis here that blessing
being tied to the fact that God has made
covenant uh with his with his people.
>> Lennox Walter Martin, it's been uh good
to reconnect with you. Uh, Walter, you
have one more thing there you want to
add in closing. I was just wanting to
say that if the Sabbath is being shifted
into the direction of a ceremonial day
and it doesn't really matter whether you
keep that day or another,
then why is it that the evangelical
world wants to push the first day of the
week as if it were something that was
legislated in in the Bible. Uh shouldn't
they then if they want to relegate the
Sabbath to a ceremonial day be open to
having any day as the Sabbath day? Why
is it then that they particularly push
for the first day of the week? So the
divide that we have is it seems
uncomfortable that the Sabbath
commandment should just happen to be
locked into the decalogue. Uh, wouldn't
it be nicer if we could shift it away by
using Colossians chapter 2 and make it
ceremonial? But the trouble is that it's
locked into the decalogue and therefore
it is a fixture written with the finger
of God in stone. And we all know the
metaphor that we use when something is
written in stone that's where it stands.
and to try and make it more ceremonial
and at the same time legislate another
day seems to me to be a contradiction.
But be that as it may,
I think that we have sort of defined
that there are two ways of looking at
this and everybody will have to go to
the scriptures and determine for
themselves which of the two do they
think fit the pattern of scripture the
best. So it's a personal choice and in
that way the Sabbath is actually a a
beautiful test as to what your position
is going to be in terms of your
relationship with God. And that is a
personal choice that each one of us has
to make. I think if we could sum it up
like that, then u uh we get down to the
point where it is up to you
using or relying on the Holy Spirit to
convict you as to what is the scriptural
position as to a traditional position.
>> Well guys, um we are uh running out of
time here. Um and I don't want to
continue on. I think we could probably
have this very amiable discussion for
quite a bit longer and I want uh all of
you to know that I've thoroughly enjoyed
it and I've appreciated you guys coming
on.
>> Hey, I heard Lennux say that uh he would
join his Adventist brethren in making
sure that you know we we did enjoy
certain freedom. So when you join us,
Lennin, we're counting on you to stay
with us, brother. Stay with us.
>> I I absolutely will. And I and and
here's the thing. I do believe Christ is
winning. I do believe that the nations
are being discipled. It might not happen
in our lifetime. Um, but Christ is
writing a beautiful story.
>> And when all that is said and done, we
wouldn't have to be worried about
persecution of those who are truly in
Christ.
>> Well, let's uh if if you guys are all
okay with it, unless you had any other
points, I don't mean to cut anybody off
or if you had any final thoughts. Um,
let's uh go ahead and close with prayer
and uh ask the Lord to go with us as we
go from here.
Heavenly Father, thank you for your many
wonderful blessings and thank you for
this discussion. And I pray that you'd
help us to be ardent students of
scripture and to um have a deep
relationship with Jesus.